the david pakman show subreddit is
approaching a huge milestone 20000
subscribers you can find it at david
pakman.com slash re d di t couple
interesting posts from this morning lime
guy asked how many of you are friends
with trumpets do you think politics
matters with friends this is something
i've never come to a conclusion on
though i find people who believe really
dumb crap can be annoying to me like
trump apologists you know for me the
conflicts with conservative
acquaintances and friends or you are
rarely about politics themselves but
it's about something indirectly related
to their worldview so like we rarely
argue about electoral politics or
abortion or stuff like that but what
gets irritating and tends to cause
conflict is that their political views
are linked to a generally bizarre
worldview which might include you know
aggressive skepticism of science or
conspiratorial thinking about
uncontroversial institutions or whatever
the case may be
so in my experience the difficulty with
acquaintances colleagues friends that
whose politics are different is not so
much about the politics of electoral
decisions so to speak but more just that
like their politics are just part of a
worldview that to me is difficult to be
around and very often i end up sort of
opting out i'm talking about you know
pretty radical people here like some
kind of moderate centrist where we
disagree on on fiscal policy it's not
really a huge deal but but that's
typically what happens though the
arguments aren't actually about you know
social security or abortion or gay
marriage or whatever the case may be
also posted by reflex point is a very
interesting section of sam harris
interviewing andrew yang on two issues
joe biden's cognitive state as well as
tara reid i encourage people to check
this out i tend to have the same
perspective as andrew yang here he
explains when it comes to Joe Biden's
cognitive state that listen he's 78 and
and thus he is a different person
cognitively
some degree as he was when he debated
Paul Ryan eight almost nine years ago
but that Andrew yang has spent time with
him and Joe Biden is cognitively okay
and that all of the stuff that we're
seeing is is relatively overblown that
goes with what I'm seeing from the
mental health experts that I talked to
and the neurologists that I've spoken to
I would not doubt for a second that Joe
Biden is not slowed down compared to who
he was nine twelve fifteen twenty years
ago he's nearly 80 years old and this is
something that happens but I concur with
Andrew yang on that and react also says
that he does not think that the Tara
Reid story is going to explode and be
the prevailing narrative over the next
few months with Joe Biden and I also
agree with that and I've explained why
earlier this week so check out that
video if you haven't seen it and then
lastly here is a question about the
Ahmad R burry case a user named HOH H
231 says is it too soon to talk about
how the father and son who lynched the
black jogger in Georgia will likely be
found innocent I don't know that I would
even go into characterizing it as a
lynching or not and debating whether the
guy was jogging or not everybody's
disputing every one of these facts I
hate to say it I really do but if you
said David you've got a bet do those
guys end up being found guilty of any
felonies or not I say probably not
that's probably the way that I would bet
and we have to let the justice system
run its course of course the problem is
when we don't trust the justice system
to properly adjudicate certain types of
cases becomes more and more difficult to
do that but if you said David you just
you got a bet you got a bet on either
they are found not guilty or guilty of
some minor misdemeanor that they plea
down to or these individuals plead or
are found guilty to felonies I bet that
they're not found guilty of felonies
okay remember you can join the
discussion at david pakman.com slash
read it it is free to subscribe and
nearly 20,000 of you have already done
that